because in my head like isn't it  something that could be worked out like  outside of Court it is but Hearthstone  break even and  he I think in his mind he has a number  which I won't say but he has a number  that he wants to stick to and basically  when you're going through this process  for North Carolina law because it's very  different other places you don't get a  percentage if you both combined make a a  annually over 300 000 you're considered  off the charts off off grid so then at  this point you have to prove how much  you need in child support So any bills  that my son occupies rent car note cable  groceries those are things that my son  occupies and in Charlotte  um the least amount that I could that I  could get would be 50 of each of those  expenses right the most depending on his  career and what the judge sees fit it  could be up to 97 percent